thank you for coming kay could catch you
whenever you come to Japan you don't
have much time I know that so I
appreciate that you you took the time
now obviously we've worked together in
the past and we've done a number of
things like things of which I'm pretty
proud like the interview we didn't wanna
with sorry I'm a sense a number of
things Takasaki which was very intense
and rewarding
now of course today's today's interview
little bit different because now as
people know I'm not involved officially
with the IAF anymore even though I still
help out for technical things and I
think the the the way I want to ask you
late the interview today is on you as a
person as an Aikido Kyle that's okay I
will be happy to answer the majority of
the questions in an open and free way
okay that's fine so to begin you look
Japanese
but you speak better English than most
Japanese and you speak Spanish so I knew
how did that come about
tell us a little bit about your bringing
well I
[Music]
my parents were Japanese diplomats and I
spent my childhood in South America I
was born in the island of kyushu in the
city of Coca and from the age of four we
moved to Cuba and then to Bolivia and I
think in my formative years I was
exposed to a culture that was not very
typical Japanese so I started to speak
Spanish better than Japanese and
gradually I forgot Japanese and I in
those days there were no Japanese
schools for Japanese kids overseas so I
went to a local school and
I immersed I became more South American
than Japanese I returned to Japan at the
age of 11 and suddenly I was put into a
regime of study study study and I had to
catch up because I I didn't know all the
Japanese classics history I didn't know
kanji to begin with
so after tremendous hard work and I
reintegrated into the Japanese society
and I went to keio university which is
one of the best ones I would say in
Japan but for me between 11 to 18 19 it
was sort of very negative feeling
because I was suddenly brought back into
a cage and I had to behave differently
but my background is much more open and
[Music]
that is proving to be very useful for
for many things that I have done
professionally academically and so forth
so when you return to to Japan were you
where were you located the majority of
the time I when we came back was always
in Tokyo so my father retired in Tokyo
we lived in tsunami
[Music]
not too far from home boo and by
accident I started to do Aikido and I'll
be happy to talk more about that so you
you began a to do at home yes I studied
Aikido in 1969 may 7th so I I'm
celebrating over 50 years of Aikido I
never expected that I would continue to
like you this long I went to hombu dojo
with the kind introduction of an
individual who was my father's friend
who used to be a pilot in the Japanese
self-defense force and he felt that as a
Japanese man I should learn one or two
martial arts and I wasn't very
interested until I went to hombu the
mood at hombu at that time was as you
can imagine relatively gloomy because it
was so soon after all since I passed
away but I saw Aikido and removed all
the preconceived notions that I had
about martial arts and I thought oh this
is phenomenally beautiful and I think I
can do this
so it's interesting because you really
came at hombu as you said in a really
transitional time of course tomorrow
though she was in charge not been in
charge for more than 10 years before
that but of course with the passing of
us and say probably a new dynamic came
yes I in those days in 1969 1970 toh hey
coach sensei was still there he was
Shihong Bhutto and his class was super
popular I attended many of his classes
I liked him as an aikidoka he had such a
charismatic presence but of course I my
main focus was the 6:30 class for those
doshu I attended also a census Thursday
second class Sasaki since his Misano
sensei second-class ones Saturdays and
well of course I I tried with all the
senses that were so charismatic in those
days so the exposure the variety of
techniques that I could see at that time
was very very rewarding for me you
talked about toha sensing of course he
of all the Xian he had the most
experience abroad of course did you did
you find that you could connect with him
more easily than with other teachers
because of that somehow international
yes I think Tori sensor had the sense of
humor though he says he was very
expressive in the way that he taught
classes and I think many people felt
that he was a phenomenal instructor as
well as leader for Aikido I think
[Music]
unfortunately if he had stayed in Aikido
he would have added another additional
element to that but I think he tried to
challenge the lineage which i think is
not acceptable in Japan and it's too bad
for Aikido but I think we cannot help it
katakana and you may say well since you
mentioned the lineage it's unclear to me
whether itíd always been meant to be a
near moto system or not what was the to
consensus at the time when it wasn't a
passed away well I was too beginner to
be involved in such matters and I know
that later I was informed by my teacher
that I started studying when I moved to
the US to do my graduate studies
Mitsunari Kenai sensei he said that Tori
sensei had invited many of the she hunts
and high-ranking people to follow him
and Tori says he was under the
expectation that many people would
follow him and even though many people
like Torres and say I think the lineage
thing was more important for many of the
Japanese instructors so even though they
like toys and secondly they didn't go
that that is my understanding and to
follow up you were probably already in
us when Shah Mardan passed away
now did the transition to the current
doshu happen do you remember I well the
transition of course was somewhat
expected as the lineage thing was
established much further along the lines
for the wish my family and it is obvious
although it's not written anywhere that
that's the way that he's going to be has
become like de facto direction that H I
will continue to take so after a Kishore
mother those who passed away I think
everybody whether it's in I kinda was a
very smooth transition and not that I'm
aware of
people trying to split like what
happened other people have done before
and because it's a of course it's an
interesting question in the context of
of course gif and your role in the IAF
I'm not quite sure about what the
expectations of the whole Jean legal
status terraces are because the aikikai
is the hojin and it's no use any English
nonprofit organization is it supposedly
a democratic entity or is it quite free
it's in other words how does it fit with
that expected the Emoto system of
martial arts
I think they follow I was for since
nineteen
95 to 2005 more or less I was jogging of
aikikai and I attended a few meetings
and it follows the legitimate hojin or
structure the decisions I made according
to the official meetings the DG Kai and
so forth of course Japanese corporations
or public entities and many others the
decision-making process is never the
same as Western companies that have more
individualistic positions and in Japan
is I remember that many years ago they
would say that board meetings in Japan
are represented by three SS sleeping
smiling and silent and it's not
something that refers to IQ hype per se
but the Japanese arranged the consensus
beforehand so that's why they are
smiling they are sleeping because
everybody knows there's not much to talk
and they are silent because they they
all agree they have agreed to that I'm
not saying that that is the direction
but though she has some very competent
counselors supporting him to get some
ideas about how to run the operations
and so forth so in that sense you have
to say that he is structured as a proper
Public Interest legal entity does the
government have much oversight in what's
going on in those sort of entities or I
think
right now I'm not fully familiar with
that internally but the government has
created a sports agency led by mr.
Daiichi Suzuki gold medalist in swimming
and within the structure of Sports Show
and also the Japanese sport authorities
Aikido is properly is part radio of the
official establishment so unlike some
other different Aikido groups that
separated from Ike hi I you have to say
that I Kiko
Aikido Ike high is already part of
Japanese established sports community so
now within the aikikai itself as we know
it's it's a very vertical organization
certainly as fast the teaching
allocations go the rankings and so on so
I guess that brings us to the IAAF which
is and so whether that's perception or
whether that's what it is I don't know
but which seems to me like more of a
democratic entity which it holds
elections the Chairman general secretary
there are members board members so I
can't help but feel Lots by the sheer
design those organizations might perhaps
find difficult to to deal with each
other because they're really structured
very differently so I guess my question
is one is the structure responsible for
some difficulties and and the second
question part of the question would be
what is the the purpose of the IAAF
being structured as it is what does it
add to the table that the aikikai can't
necessarily do
well I have is was established more than
40 years ago and I think second dose
Rakesh Kumar doshu at at the given time
felt the necessity to form a global
organization I think there were some
issues in Europe that some groups
countries were trying to form their own
one and each guy took a preemptive
action and many of the initial members
of the board were basically high-ranking
Japanese Sheehan's
and heavily involved in the IAF nowadays
we have the IAF senior counsel and with
Tadashi Hahn at the supreme top we
sometimes ask him for opinions we really
send them updates on the activities that
we do but we have much more freedom in
what we can do of course we don't want
to create some position that goes
against the interest of each tie so the
coordination with each guy is something
that I personally take it very seriously
and one of the things that I requested
after I became a chairman was to request
that not only we meet once every four
years or we meet casually because I come
to Japan relatively frequently
I said we need to have a coordination
meeting with the whole of HCI so we are
hosting meetings once a year to to
really meet together and within the if2
we do about once a month meeting via
google hangout and we share all the
information by a Google Drive so every
member knows what's happening we send
updates of our activities to all the
member Federation's as well as senior
counsel in addition to our daily
communication with aikikai we make an
effort to communicate more to avoid
misunderstanding and some unwanted the
confrontation situation
[Music]